all right blad Smith we're just going to
jump right into this today we want to
see what you're actually capable of what
we're going to do is take odd shapes of
mystery steel and have you make your
signature Blade with those you will come
up one at a time in an order that was
randomly Chosen and you will choose your
piece of mystery steel out of this
Barrel Jordan you're up first choose
your
steel you've chosen 1084 cable 1084 was
great for me because most of my knives
are made out of that steel but I've
never forged anything out of this round
cable so I'm pretty nervous David you're
up choose your
steel I end up with 1095 cylinders nine
of them to be exact the Metal's not
difficult it's trying to weld a cylinder
to another cylinder Rick you're up
choose your
[Music]
steel that is a coil of
5160 it's just a very thick piece of
Steel and you have to figure out some
way to get it straight good luck blade
Smiths your 10-minute design window
starts now my signature plate I would
say is a viking Sachs I think the Sachs
would be a good design because it has a
broken back I'm going to make it with a
heavier spine and probably a Slimmer
Edge so the heaviness will help get
through the Terracotta the thinner Edge
will help with the
slicing the design for my ey blade is a
very large straight back Hunter with a
recurve a straight back Hunter is
something that I make quite often I
think it'll do very well with the
chopping of the Terra Cotta it's a
pretty robust
blade I'm going to go for a design of a
camp knife with a slight recurve recurve
is helpful with chopping because you get
a little bit more bite in the cut and
that's really helpful with cutting
something thick and juicy like to Tommy
mats I'm not a typical 21y old I'm
really ready to prove that even though
I'm young I am ready to start a career
as a bladesmith making some of the
finest knives in the world blad Smiths
drop your pencils Your Design window is
closed your three-hour Forge time starts
now Jordan threw his cable immediately
Into the Fire he didn't clean it he
didn't do nothing he didn't spray it
first thing sticking in the Forge
there's not a moment to lose when it
comes to just keep beating it up hey
he's bleeding he is bleeding I pinched
my thumb in the vice a couple minutes
and and I've already hurt myself what am
I like the young guy making a fool of
himself come on baby eat up the first
thing I got to do is uncoil it I want to
get it as hot as possible before I can
get it into the P
Vice I got the coil spring in the Vise
and uh I'm started to get somewhere so
now I'm just really just banging away on
that thing till I get it
straight fight me at every step how the
heck am I going to do the rest of this
challenge now with after I've expended
almost everything I got just to get this
thing straightened
out thing is fraying like crazy ah time
to cut off the
end weld the thing together so that it's
not going to
fray the hardest part about using the
cylinders is I have to make them Square
first and then put them together and
Forge welding after I did two or three
welding Heats and Consolidated the
Billet I knew it was solid yeah I got
this now that I've got the cable welded
I'm going to take it to the power hammer
and really try to refine those welds get
the corners all pounded in and then I'll
have a bar that I can use to forge I'm
going to go over to the vice and cut my
clip with the angle grinder I could
actually Forge it out but that would be
another hours worth to work and I don't
have that much time hey can you guys
just watch what's happening over here
with Rick looks like Rick is basically
going to grind his blade into a shape I
don't recommend doing that it is not
what an experience Smith does I don't
even want to watch this I can't watch
it 2 hours into the challenge I'm
feeling great my blade it looks pretty
good so far I got no cracks yet
so now I go to heat treat my blade I'm a
bit
nervous if the small cylinders didn't
well together I'm going
home and waiting to hear the bad
signs but nothing I was trying not to
jump up and down
cuz I want to quench only the edge of
the blade so that it'll get a harder
Edge is that here we go and the spinal
will stay flexible so it has good shock
absorption oh there he goes so Jordan
just quenched 5 4 3 2 1 blad SMI shut
down your machines drop your tools
secure your blades and head back to your
anvils your forging time is
over blad Smith this is the strength and
durability test I'll be taking your
blades and hammering them into these two
terracotta tiles remember it's not about
what your blade does to these tiles it's
about what these terracotta tiles do to
your blades David you ready
[Music]
absolutely well David no damage no
cracks one of the things that I don't
like about your knife is you left the
Back Square right here I would like to
have seen you round this back off a lot
more but overall not bad Jordan are you
ready go for
[Music]
it I was a little concerned about this
Edge but virtually no
damage just this little ding from the
hammer but that's to be expected Rick
you ready as ready as I'll ever
be it is a really thick Edge so this
actually was well designed for cutting
through the Terracotta tile but you have
some Edge damage wherever we laid it on
the tile and hammered it that's where
your Edge is not sharp anymore I really
didn't get as nice an edge on the blade
as I wanted too blad Smiths to see how
sharp your blades are I will take your
weapon and I will deliver a slash across
East to Tommy mats Dave you up first you
ready absolutely let's do
[Music]
this I like the overall shape of your
blade it's got a wide taper that goes
into the edge of your blades so when you
cut definitely lacerate through and cut
through the first part of the tatami mat
overall your blade will cut Jordan
you're up are you ready go for
it well Jordan your blade is one of the
lightest and skinniest but it goes to
show that you don't need a heavy blade
to be able to cut through and it's
plenty sharp your blade will cut good
job thank you Rick you're up next you
ready uh I I guess I have
[Music]
to your handle it's a little bit on the
blocky side but it is enough to grab
hold on to your Edge the profile you
have is thick so once it cuts through it
hung up in there cuz these are very
tightly wound but what we are looking
for is an edge that will lacerate your
weapon will cut thanks Doug good
job blad Smiths the judges have made
their final decision it's time for one
of you to leave the
forge Rick your blade did not make the
cut Dave will
explain Rick you came through you turned
into a blade that was tested in the end
it came down to the edge geometry of
your blade and the fact that your blade
is the least finished of all three of
our blades that's the reason we're
letting you
go Rick please surrender your blade I
knew that it was going to be difficult
but I've never been this emotional in my
entire life just I'm passionate about it
thank
you from this experience I've had a
tremendous Adventure I think I've made
some new friends but I'm ready to go
home I'm ready go back to my
[Music]
family